As with most things in machine knitting
there are many ways to add
a folded band to a sweater.
Let's take a look at one method
of adding a plain stockinette
band to some fairisle knitting.
This sample represents the front of
a cardigan. In a real project.
For accuracy, I would measure the front
edge and then I'd establish
my stitch gauge in stockinette.
Multiply the length of the front
by my stitch stitch gauge.
And I'll know exactly how
many stitches to pick up.
For this sample, I'm simply holding
the knitting up to the needle bed, and.
I'll pick up approximately three
stitches for every four rows.
With practice, you'll be able to eyeball.
This. With the WRONG SIDE facing.
I'll hang both edges and then the center.
I'll continue to divide the sections
in half, hanging the stitches neatly.
Be careful when picking up.
I didn't look closely before I started
knitting, and you can see the hole.
This was caused by hanging the same.
Space in the knitting on two
needles side by side.
So don't do as I did.
Double check the stitches
before you start knitting.
Grading the band is helpful
in keeping it from flipping out.
Knit the inside or the private side
of the band at a slightly tighter.
Tension than the outside
or the public side.
This will force the band to curl
towards the inside slightly.
Knit the first
section of the band,
and then knit a turning row.
I just knit one row at a
very loose tension to create a crease.
Then knit the second side of the band.
Let's look at two ways to secure the band.
First, pick up the edge stitches
and hang them on the needles.
And loosely bind off these stitches.
Now, I don't prefer this method.
It adds bulk and it's difficult
to get the bind off just right.
Not too loose and not too tight.
The second method is to scrap
off the band stitches.
Since I'm going to be hand stitching.
Those live stitches, I knit a row
Of ravel cord and then
scrapped off in yarn.
I find it easier to stitch from.
The cord instead of from the yarn.
With the live stitches secure, it's time
to close up this section of the band.
I'll just whip stitch those
live stitches in place.
I suggest you practice both
methods and see what you prefer.